warum existiert nicht nichts märz denkt
man darüber nach wie sie existiert
überhaupt etwas wie so existiere ich
wieso existierst du wieso existiert
leben und es existiert das universum so
wie es ist
je länger man über diese frage nachdenkt
und wenn einem der volle umfang dieser
frage bewusst wird dann fällt einem auf
dass es eigentlich die frage ist die
frage nach dem ursprung und unseren
platz in der welt
nichts ist ein schwieriges konzept sogar
so schwierig dass man sich eigentlich
gar nicht nichts vorstellen kann wenn
man über nichts redet wenn man schnell
über falsche nichts nach über sachen die
trotzdem etwas sind zum beispiel schwarz
schwarz ist eine wahrnehmung die nicht
im nichts existieren würde oder ein
vakuum in dem definitiv etwas passiert
ständig kommen sich materie und
antimaterie teilchen und zerstrahlen zu
reiner energie
dann kann man sich vorstellen was
außerhalb unseres universums ist
außerhalb der grenzen unserer raumzeit
müsste doch nicht sein
aber selbst in dieser realität gibt es
irgendwo unser universum und damit
definitiv etwas und vor dem urknall was
existierte da kaum zeit und
physikalische gesetze masse und energie
kraftfelder all das existierte doch erst
mit dem urknall
aber selbst wenn vor dem urknall keine
zeit war in diesem sinne gab es ja dann
doch irgendwann den urknall und damit
nicht nichts
ich glaube wahres echtes nichts kann man
sich nicht vorstellen aber das macht die
frage noch interessanter wie kann aus
purem nichts etwas entstehen
energie kann laut dem energie
erhaltungssatzung wieder kreiert noch
zerstört werden
das ist eines der fundamentalsten
gesetze unserer physik aber woher kommt
dieser ursprüngliche pool an energie und
wieso ist es exakt diese menge ich finde
es einfach super spannend darüber
nachzudenken
und selbst wenn wir akzeptieren dass wir
nicht wissen können was vor dem urknall
war und warum etwas existiert dann ist
es doch super spannend zu fragen warum
unser universum so ist wie es ist
am large hadron collider am cern in der
schweiz lassen viele der besten
wissenschaftler der welt in einem 27
kilometer langen tunnel unter der erde
teilchen mit beinahe
lichtgeschwindigkeit aufeinander treffen
um zu sehen was passiert
sie betreiben grundlagenforschung und
2012 konnten sie einen riesigen erfolg
verbuchen
man hatte das sagenumwobene higgs boson
gefunden und damit die existenz eines
feldes nachgewiesen
das feld ist quasi die andere
kraftfelder zwei magnete die sich
gegenseitig anziehen oder abstoßen
wir sitzen zum beispiel magnetfelder
aber im gegensatz zu diesen
magnetfeldern ist das fixe fällt überall
im universum gleich stark dass hitzfeld
ist für uns unglaublich wichtig denn es
gibt jedem elementarteilchen seine masse
ohne es könnte nichts entstehen keine
sterne keine planeten und definitiv kein
leben es könnten sich nicht einmal atome
formen so wichtig ist dass hitzfeld für
uns aber eine sache über dieses feld ist
sehr mysteriös und auch extrem angst
einflößend mit hilfe von
relativitätstheorie und quantenmechanik
fand man heraus dass das higgs fällt
eigentlich die näher sein sollte
es ist entweder aus und hat überall im
universum den wert null oder aber es ist
an und hat überall den gleichen enorm
großen wert in beiden fällen könnten
atome nicht existieren das universum wie
wir es kennen sollte eigentlich gar
nicht möglich sein
aber anstatt komplett an oder aus zu
sein ist das feld nur leicht an
es ist nicht aus aber es ist 10
quadrigen mal schwächer als der an
zustand wie ein lichtschalter dem mann
aus balanciert hat der auf der kippe ist
nun es gibt einige erklärungen dafür
warum das feld den wert hat dem es hat
aber alle erklärungen setzen voraus dass
wir am lhc weitere teilchen finden
werden die diese tieferen mechaniken
erklären und das ist bis heute nicht
passiert
aber gut ich will keine panik machen es
kann ja durchaus sein dass wir in
zukunft noch weitere teilchen finden
werden vor allem dann der
teilchenbeschleuniger hat seit 2015 mit
doppelter energie läuft aber es gibt
noch eine zweite zahl eine weitere
prognose über den zustand unseres
universums dunkle energie ist die kraft
die unser universum auseinandertreibt
entgegen der gravitation sorgt sie dafür
dass sich galaxien immer weiter
voneinander entfernen und sich unser
universum ausdehnt
berechnet man den wert den dunkle
energie haben sollte kann man auf einen
wert der 10 hoch 120 mal größer ist als
der echte messbare wert das ist eine
eins mit 120 nullen eine zahl die so
unglaublich groß ist dass der
menschliche verstand sie niemals
nachvollziehen kann
es ist eine zahl die 1000 trillionen
trillionen trillionen mal größer ist als
die anzahl von atomen im universum wäre
dunkle energie auch nur halbwegs so
stark wie sie eigentlich sein müsste
dann würde sie unser universum zerreißen
sterne und planeten wäre nicht möglich
von leben ganz zu schweigen und im
gegensatz zum higgs fällt gibt es
hierfür einfach keine erklärung
nun zumindest keine direkte erklärung
aber die stringtheorie bietet hier einen
interessanten ansatz sie impliziert dass
jede mögliche kombination von
physikalischen gesetzen und
naturkonstanten existiert und jeder hat
ihr eigenes universum das heißt es gibt
zehn hoch 500 verschiedene universen mit
unterschiedlichen physikalischen
gesetzen jede möglichkeit existiert
viele wenn nicht sogar die meisten
dieser universen wären extrem entweder
zieht sich alles so stark an dass das
ganze universum auf einen punkt
reduziert wird oder aber die kleinsten
teilchen können nicht zusammenhalten und
atome oder größere konstrukte können
sich gar nicht erst bilden ein
multiversum das zu einem großen teil der
schlange weil ich ist nur ganz selten
sind die physikalischen gesetze genau
richtig nur ganz selten passiert etwas
spannendes und die konstanten sind
aufeinander abgestimmt
dann können sich atome bilden und mit
noch viel mehr glück eine kettenreaktion
die wir leben nennen
und jetzt sind wir wieder am anfang
wieso existieren wir wieso ist unser
universum dieser große zufall dieser
beinahe unmögliche zu fall
aber das ist in wahrheit die falsche
frage natürlich sind wir in einem
universum das leben hervorbringen kann
in anderen universen in denen kein leben
existiert existiert auch niemand der
sich diese frage stellen kann
das ist das an tropische prinzip
millionen mal wird gewürfelt und per
zufall entschieden ob ein universum in
der lage ist leben hervorzubringen
und nur wenn es einmal funktioniert kann
auch leben entstehen das sich dann fragt
wieso existieren wir wieso hat das higgs
fällt genau den richtigen wert und wieso
ist dunkler materie nicht viel viel
stärker weil wenn diese werte anders
wehren wir uns diese frage nicht stellen
könnten
das beantwortet zwar nicht die frage
danach wie unser universum im kleinsten
detail funktioniert aber zumindest mir
gibt es etwas ruhe und gelassenheit
da unsere existenz und die existenz von
leben in gewisser art und weise
garantiert ist denn wenn es kein leben
gäbe dann kann sich auch keiner
beschweren und mit diesen worten dank
für zuschauer übrig